hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem single number
we're given a non-empty array of
integers nums and we're told that every
single element in this array appears
exactly twice except for one element and
that element only appears a single time
our goal is to find that number that
only appears once and we have to
implement our solution in linear time
and we're not even allowed to use extra
space if we were allowed to use extra
space this problem would be really
trivial if you know what a hash map is
or actually even just a hash set uh
because for every single value
like suppose we had this input array
we'd take that two add it to our hash
set so something like this and then we'd
see a second two and then we would
remove it from our hash set because
every element that appears twice is
going to be added to the hash set and
then removed from it except for that
single value like one which is going to
be added to the hash set but it's never
going to be removed so by the time our
algorithm finishes we're only going to
have a single value in our hash set and
that's the value that we're going to
return but the downside of this is in
the worst case uh we'd obviously iterate
through the entire array which is big of
and time complexity but it's also big o
of n memory complexity because we're
using a hash set is there a way to do
this solution without using any extra
memory well there definitely is a
solution and let's try to figure it out
using this example i will say that the
solution i'm about to show you is not
really easy to figure out but once
you've seen it before it's pretty easy
to implement and recognize when you can
use it so suppose we had this input
array and you'll see why i wrote it this
way in a moment so i'll just tell you
that this solution does require bit
manipulation so i'm going to take each
of these values show them in their
binary representation so 4 for example
is going to be 1 0 0. of course there's
going to be some leading zeros but we
don't really care about those 1 is going
to be represented like this 2 is going
to be represented like this okay so this
is the binary representation and once
again i'll just tell you the solution
basically we're going to use a binary
operation called xor or exclusive or and
if you don't know this operation
basically what it does is if two bits
are the exact same so 0
xor 0 is going to equal 0. also
if they are the same meaning they're
both 1 this is also going to equal 0.
but if they're different so if we had 1
and 0 that's going to be 1 and if we had
xor 1 that's going to be 1 as well so if
they're different we get one if they're
the same we get zero and the solution to
this problem is literally just taking
all these input values xor them together
and then our result is going to be that
single value in this case that single
value is 4. and if you just want to know
the solution to this problem that's
literally it but it never satisfies me
so what i'm going to do is actually
explain a bit of the intuition behind it
and the simple answer is that when you
take two values like two and two and you
xor them together of course they have
the exact same binary representation so
if you xor two values that are the exact
same of course you're gonna get zero uh
all zeros in the output because you know
the bits here are the exact same the
bits here are the exact same and they're
going to be the exact same so if the
bits are the same we get 0 in the output
and the reason that's important is
because we know that there's two twos
right so these are going to cancel out
we know that there's two ones these are
going to cancel out so we're going to be
left with only that single value and the
order that you do the xor operation in
is not important you can do it in any
order and you're going to get the same
exact result so that's the simple
explanation and i'll just talk for
another minute about if you didn't know
that xor can be done in any order could
you still figure this out what's the
intuition behind it let me just talk
about that for a minute i'm not smart
enough to figure it out just by looking
at all of these bits but we know that to
simplify it we can just look at a single
column right just one of the positions
and like i said we know that every value
in the input is going to be a duplicate
except for that single number so we're
trying to prove that we know for sure
that the bit in the output is going to
be the same bit
that comes from that single number which
is right over here we know for sure it's
gonna be zero how do we know that so
we're trying to prove that the output
bit is always gonna be the bit that
comes from the single value how do we
know that well first i'm going to prove
to you that this portion of the xor
operation is always going to evaluate to
be zero how do i know that because first
of all zeros in any xor operation i
don't change the result that means if we
had n and n could be either one or it
could be zero n x or
zero is going to equal n that's pretty
simple if you look at a couple examples
we could have one x or zero that's going
to be 1 we can have 0 x or 0 that's also
going to be 0. so basically what i'm
saying is we can ignore all of the zeros
here so i'm going to scribble that out
and scribble that out so then we're
going to be left with a bunch of ones
how many ones are we going to be left
with well it's guaranteed to be an even
number of ones i'm not counting this
position by the way i'm only counting
this portion and we know it's going to
be an even number of ones because we
have only duplicates here right it's
either going to be zero ones or it's
going to be two ones where it's going to
be four ones etc etc and we know that
duplicates always cancel out one xor one
is always going to be zero that pretty
much shows that this entire thing is
always gonna be zero so uh so this is
gonna be zero right and this is either
gonna be a one or a zero and whatever it
happens to be is going to go exactly in
the output because like i showed a
moment ago n xor with 0 is always going
to be n so that's going to be this bit
and so basically what i showed you is
not really a formal proof but i showed
you an intuitive proof for just one
column but of course we could apply that
to every single column so what we know
is all of this is going to be gone and
this is going to be the output after we
do xor so we're going to return the
correct result for and we didn't use any
extra memory now let's jump into the
code now let's code it up and we are
going to have a result and we're going
to initialize it to zero and this is
what we're going to store our x or
result in the reason we're initializing
it to 0 is because like i mentioned any
value
n xored with 0 is always going to end up
being n so this is a good default value
to set it to and then we're just going
to go through every single value in nums
take that n and x or it with the result
and then set the result back equal to
that and then
once we've done that we
like i showed in the proof we know for
sure that the result has that single
number that we're trying to return so
now let's run the code to make sure that
it works and yes it does as you can see
on the left it works and it's pretty
efficient so i really hope that this was
helpful if it was please don't forget to
like and subscribe it really supports
the channel a lot consider checking out
my patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching